do i really give a [ __ ] should i give a
[ __ ] i don't know like
was i hurt by it yes but at the same
time i'm like
i've done nothing i've never done one
thing and i've been the most honest and
truthful and best friend to all of them
you might be wondering what the
kardashian fan thinks about larsa
pippin's candid appearance on the
hollywood raw podcast
you know the one where she said kim
kardashian's hubby kanye west was
responsible for breaking up their
friendship
and quote brainwashing the fam he
literally has brainwashed the whole
family into thinking that like
i don't even know what i don't even know
well a source tells et that the
kardashians aren't paying much attention
to it
quote they know why they aren't close to
larsa anymore and she's in
my personality but she did claim that
she dated the nba star
before he met chloe before chloe or any
of them even knew he existed
i was seeing him i had him come to la i
brought him to
a party kim had i introduced him to all
of them and then a week later
maybe 10 days later he started seeing
chloe which is fine i don't even care
on monday kylie jenner's former bestie
jordan woods
who was involved in her own cheating
scandal with tristan in 2019
you know things happen and of course i'm
sorry cryptically tweeted quote
make it make sense which some fans
thought was in response to larsa's
interview
it's hurtful that people think like i
hooked up like i'm trying to ruin like
chloe's life
but our source says the famous fam isn't
bothered by the former real housewives
of miami star's comments
about tristan either i'm just super
happy and content
quote at the end of the day chloe and
tristan are in a great place
as are kim and kanye larsa continues to
say she doesn't care about no longer
being close to the family but people
close to her know she does care and
continues to talk about it
of course all this comes after
eagle-eyed fans noticed back in july
that
kim chloe and courtney had all
unfollowed larsa
and she had unfollowed them too kanye
then tweeted
larsa without any explanation before
deleting it
during larsa's interview she claimed
kanye felt threatened by her
relationship with his wife
but she says she wasn't bothered when
kim gave her the old
unfollow if kanye feels like
kim and you know him are better without
me then let them be without me i'm okay
with that i have my
do i look like i'm suffering do i look
like i'm in pain i'm okay i will survive
was it hurtful yes but do i have love
from a lot of other places yes so
this shall pass too